[Music]
I told the history teacher of my plan
and he said Fox you're never going to be
queued forever you know I had no idea
what I was doing I went out you know and
I never thought that I would be back
here you know I'm just trying to matter
and live a good life and make work that
means something to somebody the people
who taught me good or bad how to fail
how to love I have to thank everyone
from the very onset of my career Mr
Caton Jones Stacy Snyder and Stacy sheer
and I can't believe I'm remembering
everybody's name but believing that I
could do it and now tonight I have this
I'm gonna find you all individually and
I'm gonna thank you all along with my
friends who I love so much I'm gonna hug
the hell out of you whatever it is we
look up to whoever it is we're chasing
that I say all right all right all right
you just gotta keep living man